what's up theo this is a deluxe calling
from new york city
and if i was going to take a man on a
date
no homo although he might be a little
questionable
i would take bobby lee out on a date and
this is what i would do i would get him
a little 1920s
young boy sailor costume and a big
lollipop
and walk hand in hand with him
and take him to a fair and win him
stuffed animals
take him on lots of rides feed him
cotton candy and elephant ears
so he was about to burst
and i would take a picture with them
in like one of those old-timey picture
places
where they dress us up like civil war
heroes
and then i would take him home
and tuck him into bed and thank him no
homo
love you theo apo
this is shane in west virginia and
before you say it
yeah most of us are overweight
i get it but you had a thing on a
recent podcast that thing about if you
were a straight male where would you
take uh another straight man on a date
i don't even think it's a real question
i mean
you would go see the baddest former
police officer
east texas has ever seen
but they got him locked up on some bogus
charges
and you go to the greater wynwood
exotic animal park aka
gw zoo in winwood oklahoma
it's not even a question where you would
take another straight
and use quotation mail
or you could be a real [ __ ] sucker and
go to the big cat rescue
tampa [ __ ] tampa [ __ ]
carol bass [ __ ] big cat rescue
take another straight mail to greater
winwood
hey theo this is jr from jersey
uh love your show uh you were talking to
a guy
about if you took a guy
out on a date what would it be like and
i thought first of all that guy was
definitely flirting with you
anyway uh if i was to take a man out
on a date uh it would be
like you know it would be like a mandate
like we would like go fishing
you know maybe like kill an animal you
know eat it
cook it and then like you know all
dressing like a
like camouflage and all that and then i
like
and just grab them and like bush [ __ ]
them real quick like that kind of thing
you know
like a real man you know and uh like up
like broke back you know like broke back
mountain
and i read that i had to read that from
college and i've never seen the movie i
kind of knew what it was about
but when you read it like all of a
sudden the guy just grabs the other guy
and he just like
he just like slammed him and uh it was
disturbing
but that's the kind of date i guess i'll
be on the whole time
i just like i ain't gay you know what i
mean
and uh yeah that's how it would be super
manly love you man love your [ __ ]
bye hey yo what's up my man
it's mitchell calling from california
in los angeles calling just to answer
question if
uh um you called to all straight men
looking to take a man on a date i think
i'd take
someone on a date to the dodger game
trying to see what that bad boy can
handle with that
uh that dodger dog you know see what
what kind of
mustard or ketchup or you know see what
see what he's working with and see if he
goes all beat
or if he just wants a normal dodger dog
and then see how he handles that that
good old prank you know yeah so that's
that's my thoughts on that
definitely the dodger game gang gang
theo
hey theo this is steve kenny from saxton
missouri
i was just going to give you a little
rebuttal on your question of
where a straight man would take another
straight man on a first date
i'd probably start it off by hitting a
ditch doing a little bit of fishing
trying to catch that catfish hitting
then i'd probably take them to
this little restaurant near me called
lambert's cafe homer
throw rolls baby i'd probably end it
by hitting some little dive bar hoping
for a leg he's not special
seeing what happens from there anyways
man love you love the podcast
keep good work gang gang brother
a theo and fellow this past
weekend listeners i just wanted to call
and uh
entertain the idea of what i would do if
i took a man out
my name is jefferson from denver forgot
to
add that but uh the idea of taking
someone out i guess you got to put
yourself in a mind state of what you
would want
you know so i guess in that case i would
uh
i wouldn't go anywhere i just buy due to
12-pack
turn on a baseball game and in the
spirit of
me not putting myself in this situation
i just pay a prostitute to give dude a
[ __ ] then she can leave it he can
enjoy the game
and then i'll just hang out with a dude
we'll both drink some beers
i guess that's about what i would do
gang gang
hey video this is zach from indiana uh
so i'm thinking about your question so
if i were to go gay or if i were to take
a man out on a date either way
um first off let me get this out of the
way
if i were to switch sides it'd probably
have to be like a top shelf kind of guy
like uh don julio of the tequila's type
of guy you know
or i would say that most interesting man
in the world that type of guy like
anyways before i get off topic so
honestly i would probably look for what
i look for in a female somebody who i
enjoy doing activities with
somebody who i get along with i don't
argue with so
i like hiking so on a first date [ __ ]
we'll go on a hike
catch a little sunrise get a little
tongue action
by the beach i live right by the indiana
dunes get a little hike on get a little
sweaty then come home and get a little
sweaty you know what i'm saying so
if i'm gonna do it that's what i would
do with a girl so i probably did the
same thing with a guy
anyways i've been a a fan for for a
little bit
here and uh keep keep doing what you're
doing do i uh
definitely enjoy your podcast i think
what you do uh is important
and i think that you uh help people in
in a way
so i appreciate it have a good day
brother
yo theo it's uh your boy g baby from
chicago
just saw your uh china dragon
and i was responding about the the
straight mandate
and uh you got to take them the hooters
man you know
catch a little tit you know god you know
god god made us that way
and uh i think that'd be a good time for
me and him
maybe do a little topgolf after you know
get a drink on
and you know call it a good night you
know maybe
walk him to his front door you know but
don't you know don't kiss him because
we're straight but just make sure he
gets home safe and that's what
you know being a good straight man is uh
what it's about
all right man love you hey hey this is
uh
kyle from charleston south carolina just
calling in to answer a question about
where would i take
a man you know if i were into that kind
of thing where would i take him
where will we go out towards the evening
there's only one place i can think of
and that is frozen option
you know what i mean go get a tan go get
some nice blueberries i discovered
blueberries there now keep that in mind
i didn't know about him i went there
some young man he said listen
you gotta try the blueberries i said oh
man
i love me some blueberries now thank you
thank you for that thea
but um you know other than that i think
we need to go stroll down
folly beach you know drive on up to
to the surrounding towns and have a
little shopping encounter
you know go back down to the to mount
pleasant you know what i mean
but uh yeah that's probably what i do
but keep in mind now i'm happily married
but
sometimes you know the mind's got to
venture in that territory in order
to always be prepared for every possible
situation
thank you i appreciate it make sure you
get craig conan on there sometime
thank you